hi I'm Eli Roth and this is my guide to
cannibalism a cannibal by definition is
someone that eats flesh of its own
species so if you were a chicken and you
ate another chicken that would be
cannibalism and if you're a human and
you eat human flesh that is cannibalism
people eat other people for a number of
reasons sometimes it's out of
desperation if you think about the org Y
and soccer team that crashed in the
Andes there was a film made about it
called alive they were stuck in the snow
they had no meat left to eat and they
had to eat each other it's not just
always for survival the osmotic ocean
app in New Guinea they ate people
because they believed they were
absorbing the power of that person and
the spirit of their ancestors would be
set free this guy general butt naked in
the wars in Liberia he would eat the
heart of a child before they would go
into battle they would bring out a child
kill the child eat the heart and then go
into battle I had a pet pig so I don't
eat pork because it reminds me of my Pig
but I've heard that human meat tastes
like pork the truth is a fatter person
would have a lot more flavor I wouldn't
want that I would want a lean piece of
meat probably not something too tough I
think the buttocks the rump that's gonna
be a good strong part of the body on
anybody like right now
food supplies disappearing and now
that's like how are we gonna feed
everybody well the answer is cannibalism
they say that a human body has enough
protein to feed 60 people well
everybody's going to die so what are we
gonna do with our bodies I mean we don't
need them anymore so why don't they go
to someone else all the starving people
in the world could be fed by a human
meat which be a kind of probably a much
greener way of recycling dead bodies
than we currently have where our bodies
are pumped full of poison and then
stuffed into the ground we could just
eat the bodies well then that's a great
way of helping save the planet